Well,
now I have to fight this guy because he,
I don't even like this girl really.
So now it's like a,
but it's a,
it's a weird thing.
So I just pretended I didn't hear him.
I was like long ago,
that was always kind of like scuffled and I was like,
that was that.
And she's like,
did you hear what he said?
I was like,
no.
Well,
he's telling him,
man,
you had to fight for my,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
but I dated girls like that,
that will you get in your head stopped.
She's like,
I'm going to get a hot dog.
I've had,
I've had girls that I've dated that would want you to fight for them.
Not what they would just ladies,
if any ladies listen to the show,
all three or four ladies that are listening to this show right now,
if I just don't get your man into a fight,
let him decide.
Don't start talking shit to another dude.
You're,
you're putting him in a situation that maybe he doesn't want to be in and you're
never going to know whether or not he wants to be in that situation.
You're never going to get the honest story.
What's going on in his fucking mind right there just no,
we never want you to start talking shit to a dude in the middle of an
altercation cause it's never gonna end good.
No.
Most of the time,
most of the time does not end good.
Especially if blows start flying,
man.
People getting knocked out.
Some guy got hurt really bad at a Dodgers game recently.
He got knocked out and cracked his head off the ground.
That's what people need to understand.
People die from that shit.
Watch movies and people knock people out in the person's fine.
Yeah,
you could get a goddamn murder rap if you punch someone and they fall.
And most people,
when you punch him in the face that go unconscious,
they have no idea what happened.
They go unconscious,
their head bounces off the ground,
they die.
It happens all the time.
Kevin James when he was a kid when he was a bouncer in Long Island and one of
the guys at the bar,
I don't think he was working that night,
but one of the guys he knew and worked with knocked the guy out.
The guy fell,
hit his head off a curb.
Dead Guy went up to going to going to jail for years,
spent years in jail at some fucking $10 an hour job or you fight and drunks.
Yeah,
just getting into some dumb fight,
which is thinking it's okay to just tee off on someone's face.
It's also probably pretty rare people falling and hitting their head and dying.
That's not rare at all.
That's really common.
Think about what that is.
Somebody I've seen a lot of people get knocked out,
so I'm the wrong guy to ask,
but I'm saying dying from hitting their head on the car.
I haven't seen him die,
but they could easily,
yeah,
I mean I guarantee you in a major city like New York,
I bet somebody dies falling and hitting their head off the curb every week.
When you punch someone and they fall.
Think about how far that is,
right?
Think about the amount of force that's involved.
Now think about if you were standing there and someone hit you in the back of
the head with something.
Now think about that.
Something was the fucking world.
The earth,
it doesn't give it all concrete doesn't give it all.
The only thing that gives your head,
your head has to bounce and your skull fractures and you get internal bleeding.
Your brain hemorrhages,
it cuts off your ability to move.
You might have a stroke,
you might have,
I mean,
it's horrible.
Getting knocked out and falling in,
hitting your head off the ground is a terrifying thing.
And when you hear the sound of smack of someone's head bouncing off the
concrete,
it's,
it sounds hollow.
That sounds like a,
like a,
like a melon.
It sounds terrible.
Like
a hard melon or something like that.
Yeah.
You see it happen.
Um,
where people pass out,
there's like videos that are out there and just like fall over and then they
just split their head open.
Worse Dude,
gruesome falling backwards though.
There's something,
especially when you get hit,
you get fucking clipped on the chin years,
head snaps and you lights shut off and you just fall and bounce.
It's even in boxing matches men.
So then the scariest knockouts when a guy gets k out and then his head bounces
off the ground and MMA and the UFC,
same thing when guys fall back and their head bounced off the ground.
It's like a double knot.
That's what I watched that fight science thing back in the day they were doing
on spike TV and I was like a show called,
I think it was called fight science and they were just explaining why ground and
pound was so much more brutal than a straight up standing punch and they were
just,
they like,
you know,
they showed the three d animation of the head and the fist coming down and then
the head bouncing off the mat and then the brain bouncing off the front and
bouncing to the back.
Then the fist comes back up again and your brain is just being over and over
again and you can't go anywhere.
You're stuck.
It's terrifying.
I got beat up in the sixth grade by an African kid named Bubba tuneday analysts.
Every day a hundred,
right.
53 people in the United States die from injuries that include traumatic brain
injury when,
wait a minute.
Okay.
That include traumatic brain injury.
So it's an injury that also has traumatic brain injury.
I see what they're saying.
Those who survive a Tbi can face effects that lasts a few days or the rest of
their lives.
That's the other thing.
Impair thinking or memory movements,
sensation,
vision,
emotional functioning,
personality changes or depression.
These issues not only affect individuals can have lasting effects on families.
The community.
Well that's,
yeah.
Um,
yeah man,
don't,
don't get hit in the head.
Dot.
Yeah.
Take her for somebody that's been hitting the head.
Avoid it.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
w whenever,
when my son,
cause there's just like a lot of,
there's a weird thing in New York as well where there's like a lot of tough guys
that it's like this Alpha energy we'll get on the subway and there's another
dude who like make eye contact with you and then you're like,
weirdly like you're in a weird beef now cause you're just looking at a dude in
the eyes and look.
Yeah.
And it's in that,
and then it becomes a thing where you have to like look away.
Then you're,
you have this internal struggle where we're going like,
well no I don't,
I'm not going to look away because this guy's looking at me and then,
and then I looked at my kids right there and I'm going like,
what is even going on in my head right now?
I need to just go to another subway car.
Just avoid at all costs having to get into a confrontation in front of him
because that's one of my biggest fears in the world is not knowing what to do.
This people
in like Montana that are listening to this right now,
they're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like you look each other in the eye and some wants to fight for no reason.
This is the nature of being penned up.
Yeah,
that many people,
I was fucking does something cool about it.
The cool thing we talked about before that people are like,
you are exposed.
Even if you're a poor kid,
you're exposed to rich people.
They're,
they're,
they're normal.
They're like,
it doesn't seem unattainable or unreachable.
They're all around you.
The Path is there.
Well,
there are humans that are,
they're just like you.
You're around them.
But if you live in a place where there you're never around them,
you'll never get that.
So there's benefits to New York for sure.
Culturally,
there's benefits.
The just the,
just the energy,
the city,
and so much creativity.
So much going on.
Yeah.